war zone 2 details have reportedly
leaked death stranding 2 seems to be in
production and skyrim just skyrim
according to a new report from exputer
warzone 2 or whatever it will be called
will include an interrogation feature
similar to how it works in rainbow six
siege players will be able to
interrogate downed enemies to reveal
their teammate's location i really want
my character to interrogate like
christian bale's batman
adding to this armor vest will
reportedly be in war zone 2 as well and
range from tier 1 to 3. each tier allows
players to equip more armor plates which
slot into the vest and just how it works
in existing warzone plates can break but
vests can't war zone 2 may also
incorporate a bag system similar to the
one in escape from tarkov bags can
contain ammo killstreaks and weapons and
higher bag tiers provide additional
storage space the report goes on to say
that war zone 2 will have pro perks
which are beefed up versions of standard
perks these pro perks can be obtained by
looting new locations called strongholds
strongholds are reportedly locations on
war zone 2's map that are protected by
ai soldiers and contain objectives for
players to complete as part of a meta
game system it's important to note that
all of the information mentioned here is
only according to reports aka not final
aka subject to change so don't go
strategizing with your clan just yet
warzone 2 is expected to be released in
2023 following the launch of call of
duty modern warfare 2 later this year
while activision has announced the next
war zone and modern warfare 2 the
publisher has yet to fully reveal both
titles keep checking back with gamespot
for more information and sticking with
the sequel talk actor norman reedus has
revealed that development has begun on
death stranding 2. the game has not been
announced but norman plainly told leo
edit that quote we just started the
second one however don't get too excited
because reedus also said it took maybe
two or three years to finish the motion
capture scenes for the original death
stranding so death stranding 2 might not
be here anytime soon if his work has
just begun the original death stranding
sold more than 5 million copies before
the launch of the director's cut so it
sure seems like the game was a hit sony
published the ps4 and ps5 edition with
505 games handling the pc release in
2020. before this interview with reedus
it was reported that death straining
studio kojima productions might be
working on an xbox exclusive game we'll
keep an eye on this story and report
more details as they become available
but for now let's end your week by
talking about a game that will never die
the elder scrolls 5 skyrim the game's
anniversary edition released in 2021 for
xbox playstation mpc to celebrate the
game's 10th anniversary is now
reportedly heading to switch switch
brazil reports that taiwan's digital
game rating committee listed the skyrim
anniversary edition for switch
suggesting an official announcement
might not be too far off the base
version is already available on switch
but not the anniversary edition and
given the switch has an install base of
more than 100 million units it would
seem to make commercial sense to bring
the game to nintendo's hybrid so are you
planning on buying skyrim again or have
you somehow never played it let me know
and i'll see you again on monday
you